La supraconductivité, c’est le fait
pour un matériau
de conduire parfaitement l’électricité,
sans aucune résistance.
On voit l’idée, mais ce qui est bizarre,
c’est que le genre d’images
qu’on associe toujours à la supraconductivité,
c’est ça.
Une photo d’un aimant qui lévite au-dessus
d’un supraconducteur,
le tout dans un nuage de fumée.
Vous pouvez regarder vous-même:
si on en croit Google Images,
la représentation universelle
de la supraconductivité,
c’est ce phénomène de lévitation.
Et là j’avoue que pendant longtemps j’ai
pas bien vu le rapport.
Pourquoi est-ce que quand on parle
de supraconductivité
on montre ce genre d’images?
Conduire l’électricité sans résistance,
je peux comprendre.
Mais c’est quoi le lien avec
la lévitation et les aimants?
Il n’y a même pas de circuit
électrique sur ces photos.
Où est le rapport?
Eh bien c’est de ça qu’on va parler
aujourd’hui,
et vous allez voir que le lien est loin
d’être si évident que ça.
[jingle]
La supraconductivité, c’est un phénomène
découvert en 1911
par le physicien néerlandais
Heike Kamerlingh Onnes.
Trois ans plus tôt, en 1908, Onnes
avait mis au point un procédé
pour produire de l’hélium liquide,
permettant d’atteindre des température
inférieures à 4 Kelvins.
4 Kelvins c’est 4 degrés au-dessus du zéro
absolu, donc environ —269°C.
Suite à cette découverte, Onnes avait voulu
étudier la façon
dont la résistance d’un métal décroît
avec la température.
Il s’attendait à ce la résistance devienne
de plus en plus basse
au fur et à mesure que la température
diminuait.
Mais à sa grande surprise, il découvrit
dans le cas du mercure
que sa résistance électrique
chutait brutalement
autour de 4K, pour devenir nulle,
ou du moins impossible à mesurer
avec son équipement.
Onnes venait de découvrir le phénomène
de supraconductivité:
le fait que certains matériaux,
quand on les refroidit suffisamment,
se mettent à avoir une résistance
électrique nulle.
Dans les années qui suivirent, on découvrit
le même phénomène
dans d’autres métaux comme le plomb
ou le niobium,
avec des températures de transition
légèrement différentes.
On connait aujourd’hui des dizaines
de matériaux supraconducteurs,
et à chaque fois le phénomène est le même:
en-dessous d’une certaine température,
qu’on appelle leur température critique,
leur résistance électrique devient nulle.
Comme vous le voyez, aucune histoire
de lévitation là-dedans.
Et d’ailleurs ça n’est qu’en 1933,
plus de deux décennies après Onnes,
que les physiciens allemands Meissner
et Ochsenfeld découvrirent ce phénomène
de lévitation des supraconducteurs
dans un champ magnétique.
Celui qu’on voit sur toutes ces photos.
Dans les conférences du physicien
Julien Bobroff, que je vous recommande,
vous pouvez le voir réaliser l’expérience
en direct, c’est assez spectaculaire.
Il faut un aimant et une céramique
supraconductrice.
Avec de l’azote liquide, on refroidit
la céramique,
et quand on atteint sa température critique,
l’aimant se met à léviter au-dessus
du supraconducteur.
L’inverse marche aussi, on peut faire léviter
un supraconducteur au-dessus d’un aimant.
Ce phénomène, on l’appelle l’effet Meissner,
et il semble se produire
avec tous les matériaux supraconducteurs
que l’on connaisse.
Mais, j’en reviens à ma question de départ:
c’est quoi le rapport entre ce phénomène
de lévitation magnétique,
et le fait de conduire le courant
sans aucune résistance?
Pour le comprendre, commençons par cette
histoire de résistance nulle.
Vous le savez sans doute, en électricité
il y a une loi extrêmement importante,
c’est la loi d’Ohm: U = RI.
En pratique on l’utilise d’ailleurs
souvent sous la forme I = U/R.
Si vous avez une résistance R, et que vous
appliquez une tension U à ses bornes,
par exemple avec une pile: vous pouvez
alors calculer
l’intensité I du courant électrique
qui va circuler,
et elle sera égale à U/R.
I = U/R ça nous dit notamment
que pour une tension U donnée,
plus la résistance est faible,
plus l’intensité sera importante.
Généralement quand on considère des schémas
de montages électriques,
on fait comme si les fils avaient
une résistance nulle.
Mais strictement parlant, ça n’est pas vrai.
Par exemple le cuivre est très bon conducteur
de l’électricité,
mais pas un conducteur parfait.
Donc un fil de cuivre a une certaine
résistance.
Si on s’amuse à connecter les bornes
d’une pile avec un fil,
comme la résistance est très faible,
l’intensité du courant sera très élevée:
on crée un court-circuit.
Ça va chauffer, la pile va se vider très vite.
Mais pour autant la résistance du fil
n’est pas nulle,
et la loi d’Ohm s’applique quand même.
Un fil de cuivre n’est pas un conducteur
parfait.
Alors qu’un supraconducteur, ce serait
supposément un matériau
avec une résistance vraiment égale à zéro,
parfaitement nulle.
Mais alors, si on prend la loi d’Ohm
I = U/R,
ça voudrait dire qu’il y aurait
un courant infini dedans?
Eh bien non, et pour le comprendre, il faut
revenir au sens physique de la loi d’Ohm.
Dans un conducteur électrique, la tension U
qui règne se comporte comme une force
qui met en mouvement les électrons.
Formellement, la tension est liée au champ
électrique qui règne dans le conducteur.
Et c’est ce champ électrique qui exerce
une force sur les électrons
pour les déplacer, et donner naissance
au courant.
Et l’intensité I du courant, c’est en gros
le débit des électrons qui circulent
dans le fil.
Cette intensité est notamment proportionnelle
à la vitesse des électrons qui se déplacent.
Donc dans les grandes lignes, la loi d’Ohm
I = U/R
nous dit que la vitesse des électrons est
proportionnelle à la force
qui s’applique sur eux, et la résistance
joue sur le coefficient de proportionnalité.
Réfléchissez un peu cette expression:
la vitesse est proportionnelle
à la force appliquée.
C’est assez étrange comme relation non?
Pourquoi?
Eh bien comparez ça à la loi de Newton,
qui nous dit que la force est égale à la
masse fois l'accélération.
Newton nous dit F = m fois a,
donc que c’est l’accélération
qui est proportionnelle à la force,
et c’est une loi universelle en physique.
Pourquoi pour des électrons
ce serait différent.
Pourquoi pour eux, c’est la vitesse qui
est proportionnelle à la force?
Pour comprendre comment réconcilier tout ça,
penchons nous justement sur la loi
de Newton
dans son cas le plus simple:
la chute libre.
Si on lâche une masse m dans un champ
de pesanteur g,
la seule force appliquée sera le poids: mg.
Et la loi de Newton "Force = ma" nous donne
simplement que l’accélération, c’est g.
Donc dans un champ de pesanteur uniforme,
l’accélération sera constante.
La vitesse, elle, sera égale à g fois t,
où t c’est le temps écoulé.
Ce qui veut dire que la vitesse augmentera
de façon linéaire
au fur et à mesure que le temps passe.
Évidemment, c’est très théorique. Vous
vous doutez qu’en situation réelle,
la vitesse ne peut pas augmenter
indéfiniment.
Par exemple quand un parachutiste se lance
en chute libre depuis un avion,
il est très fortement freiné
par les frottements de l’air.
On peut modéliser simplement l’effet
des frottements de l’air
comme une force qui s’oppose au mouvement,
et proportionnelle à la vitesse v.
Son intensité est égale à moins k fois v,
où k un coefficient qui va notamment dépendre
de la densité de l’air,
mais aussi de la forme de l’objet qui chute.
Si on intègre cette nouvelle force
dans l’équation de Newton, ça change tout.
Plus la vitesse augmente,
plus les frottements augmentent.
On peut visualiser l’évolution de la vitesse
et voir qu’elle finit par saturer:
en chute libre dans l’atmosphère,
un masse atteindra
une vitesse limite, égale à mg divisé par k.
Et là c’est très intéressant, mg c’est
la force de gravité,
k c’est une sorte de résistance de l’air,
et on trouve que la vitesse est égale
à la force divisée par la résistance.
Exactement le genre de relation qu’on avait
dans le cas de la loi d’Ohm.
Revenons donc à cette loi d’Ohm.
Ce qu’elle traduit en fait, c’est que
les électrons sont mis
en mouvement par la tension, mais sont
freinés par la résistance du matériau.
Comme dans la chute dans l’atmosphère,
le bilan de ces deux phénomènes,
c’est que les électrons atteignent
une vitesse limite
qui est celle qu’on retrouve dans
l’intensité du courant
qui s’établit, et qui suit la loi d’Ohm.
Vous pouvez d’ailleurs faire un petit calcul
d’ordre de grandeur,
et vous verrez que dans les cas pratiques,
cette vitesse sera typiquement
de seulement quelques centimètres par seconde.
Maintenant, pour comprendre ce qu’il se
passe avec un conducteur de résistance nulle,
il ne faut pas chercher à appliquer naïvement
la loi d’Ohm et prendre R=0.
C’est comme dans l’expression de la vitesse
limite en chute libre
quand il y a des frottements: si vous voulez
supprimer les frottements
vous ne pouvez pas poser k=0, il faut revenir
au cas de la chute libre « pure »,
quand la vitesse augmente au cours du temps.
Avec un conducteur parfait, ce qui va
remplacer la loi d’Ohm est donc un équivalent
de la loi de Newton, qui exprime
que la vitesse des électrons
augmente avec le temps proportionnellement
à la force.
Dans un supraconducteur, on s’attend donc
à une loi qui dit
que l’accélération des électrons
est proportionnelle à la tension,
ce qui revient à dire que l’intensité
est proportionnelle
à la tension multiplié par le temps écoulé.
Donc dans un supraconducteur auquel
on appliquerait une tension U,
on n’aurait pas une intensité infinie,
mais une intensité qui augmente
linéairement au cours du temps.
Et si on arrête d’appliquer la tension,
le courant continue de circuler
à intensité constante.
Évidemment en pratique c’est pas si facile.
Si on appliquait une tension continue avec
une pile dans un fil supraconducteur,
l’intensité ne pourrait pas augmenter
indéfiniment.
L’intensité c’est le débit des électrons,
donc on finirait par être limité
par la résistance de la pile et sa capacité
à cracher des électrons à un rythme suffisant.
Tout ce que je viens de vous écrire ici
n’est pas parfaitement rigoureux,
vous sentez bien que j’ai manipulé
les équations d’une façon un peu cavalière.
Il existe heureusement une théorie
plus formelle
qui a été proposée par les frères London
en 1935.
Dans cette théorie, il y a une équation
qui relie le flux de charge
au champ électrique.
Et cette équation exprime exactement
l’idée
que c'est l’accélération des électrons
qui est proportionnelle
à la force appliquée par le champ électrique.
C’est ce qu’on appelle la première
équation de London,
qui caractérise un conducteur parfait.
Tout ça devrait vous convaincre
qu’on comprend assez bien ce qu’est
un conducteur parfait,
capable de conduire le courant sans aucune
résistance.
Et par exemple avec la première
équation de London,
on peut calculer son comportement
dans différentes situations.
Sauf que, je sais pas vous,
mais personnellement
je ne vois toujours pas le rapport
avec la lévitation et les aimants.
Déjà a priori faire de la lévitation
magnétique avec des aimants,
ça n’a vraiment rien d’exceptionnel.
On sait que les pôles opposés
d’un aimant se repoussent,
et donc en prenant des aimants qu’on met
en opposition,
on peut faire de la lévitation.
Voilà un exemple, j’ai pris deux aimants
percés d’un trou,
je les mets sur leurs pôles opposés,
et celui du haut lévite dans le champ
magnétique de celui du bas.
Facile, aucune difficulté, pas besoin
de supraconduction ou d’azote liquide.
Évidemment dans ce genre de dispositif,
on a besoin de l’axe central,
qui sert à éviter que l’aimant ne se retourne
et que les pôles opposés ne s’attirent.
Mais sinon rien de magique.
Des aimants qui se repoussent,
et on a de la lévitation.
Mais creusons un peu, comment ça se comporte
un aimant?
On sait que si on prend deux aimants,
les pôles opposés s’attirent,
les pôles identiques se repoussent.
Mais on sait aussi qu’un aimant va attirer
certains matériaux comme le fer.
C’est assez bizarre, un aimant
a deux propriétés:
attirer le fer et attirer d’autres aimants,
et ces deux phénomènes semblent
assez différents en fait.
Pourquoi avec le fer il n’y a pas
d’histoire de pôles,
et pourquoi c’est toujours attractif,
jamais répulsif?
Eh bien c’est plus subtil qu’il n’y parait.
Commençons par expliquer ce qu’il se passe
entre deux aimants,
car c’est ça le phénomène fondamental.
On parle souvent de pôles nord et sud
pour les aimants,
mais oublions un peu cette notion,
parce que ça laisse penser
qu’il y a comme deux matières différentes,
ou encore
que les pôles sont un bout de matière
spéciale et bien localisée de l’aimant.
C’est un peu trompeur.
Voyons plutôt un aimant comme possédant
un certain axe magnétique,
comme du bois dont les fibres sont alignées
dans une certaine direction.
On va représenter cela par une flèche,
d’autant plus grande
que l’aimant est puissant.
On appelle cela le moment magnétique
de l’aimant.
Quand deux aimants sont proches,
si les axes de leurs moments sont alignés
ils vont s’attirer,
il y a une force attractive entre eux.
Si les moments sont opposés
il vont se repousser.
C’est pour ça que le comportement quand
on a deux aimants
va dépendre de leur orientation respective.
Maintenant qu’est-ce qu’il se passe quand
on approche un aimant d’un morceau de fer.
Eh bien c’est plus compliqué, car il se
produit deux phénomènes qui vont conspirer.
Premier phénomène: le champ magnétique
de l’aimant va modifier le fer…
et va le transformer provisoirement
lui-même en aimant.
Au voisinage de l’aimant, le fer va en effet
acquérir un moment magnétique
proportionnel au champ magnétique de l’aimant.
On parle d’un phénomène de
"susceptibilité magnétique".
Le fer est susceptible, s’il s’approche
d’un aimant, il devient lui-même aimant,
plus faible que l’autre toutefois.
Et deuxième phénomène, ensuite: puisque
le fer est ainsi transformé en mini-aimant,
la règle précédente s’applique, il y
a une force entre les deux.
Et comme les moments sont dans le même sens,
c’est une force attractive.
Donc un aimant attire le fer, mais vous voyez
que c’est subtil
car ça se passe en deux temps:
La présence de l’aimant induit un
moment magnétique dans l’objet en fer,
et donc une force attractive apparait.
Et on voit pourquoi la force est toujours
attractive:
le moment créé dans le fer est proportionnel
au champ magnétique,
il y a un coefficient de proportionnalité
qu’on appelle la susceptibilité.
Et vous pouvez orienter votre morceau de fer
dans le sens que vous voulez
le moment induit sera toujours parallèle
dans le même sens.
Donc on aura toujours attraction, pas comme
avec un aimant permanent
où ça va dépendre de l’orientation.
Les matériaux qui réagissent comme le fer,
on les appelle des matériaux ferromagnétiques:
ils ont une susceptibilité
relativement élevée.
Et on dit qu’elle est positive puisque
le moment créé est dans le même sens.
Mais il existe beaucoup de matériaux
qui possèdent une susceptibilité négative.
Une susceptibilité magnétique négative,
ça veut dire
que si on les soumet au champ magnétique
d’un aimant,
cela va leur induire un moment toujours
proportionnel mais opposé cette fois.
Et ces matériaux seront systématiquement
repoussés par les aimants,
quelle que soit l’orientation de l’objet.
C’est le comportement opposé
de celui du fer,
et ces matériaux qui ont une susceptibilité
négative,
on les appelle des diamagnétiques.
Il existe un matériau diamagnétique bien
connu: c’est l’eau.
Si vous soumettez une goutte d’eau
à un aimant,
du fait de sa susceptibilité négative
elle va développer un moment en opposition,
et donc être repoussée par l’aimant.
En pratique cela ne se voit que
dans des conditions très particulières,
avec un aimant très puissant.
Mais comme pour l’attraction avec le fer,
ça marche quelle que soit l’orientation.
Le fer est toujours attiré.
L’eau est toujoursrepoussée.
Et on peut s’en servir pour faire
de la lévitation.
Dans un champs magnétique suffisamment
puissant,
on peut faire léviter des gouttes d’eau.
Et en 1997, le physicien Andrew Geim
a même fait la démonstration
en faisant léviter une grenouille.
Eh bien oui les cellules qui composent le
corps d’une grenouille sont pleines d’eau,
comme pour nous, donc ça fonctionne.
Comparé à mon dispositif du début où je
retournais deux aimants en opposition,
le gros avantage de cette lévitation,
c’est que là:
pas besoin d’un axe pour stabiliser
la répulsion de la grenouille,
puisque la force est toujours répulsive
quelle que soit l’orientation.
Bon notez que pour cette expérience
de grenouille,
il aura quand même fallu un champ monstrueux
de 14 Teslas.
Mais pour ça, son auteur Andrew Geim
a reçu en 2000 le prix IgNobel,
ce prix alternatif qui récompense la science
improbable et loufoque.
Et 10 ans plus tard, il recevra le prix Nobel,
le vrai cette fois, pour la découverte
du graphène.
C’est je crois le seul scientifique a avoir
reçu les deux prix.
[Jingle]
Bien revenons à nos supraconducteurs.
J’espère vous avoir montré que la lévitation
magnétique n’a rien de mystérieux,
et surtout n’a semble-t-il pas de lien
avec le fait de conduire le courant
sans résistance électrique.
Avec un matériau diamagnétique comme l’eau,
on peut faire de la lévitation.
Alors il y a quand même une différence entre
la grenouille
et la lévitation supraconductrice.
Si vous avez regardé une expérience avec
un supraconducteur,
vous verrez vite qu’on n’a pas besoin
d’un champ magnétique monstrueux
pour avoir de la lévitation,
un aimant assez simple suffit.
D’où vient cette différence?
Eh bien c’est l’intensité
de la susceptibilité.
Pour de l’eau, la susceptibilité est égale
à environ - 1/100 000ème.
Donc en réponse à un champ magnétique,
elle crée un champ opposé, mais
100 000 fois plus petit.
C’est pour cela qu’il faut un champ
de malade pour que ça lévite.
Dans un supraconducteur, la susceptibilité
est égale à -1.
Ça veut dire qu’un supraconducteur
réagit à un aimant
en produisant un champ exactement opposé,
donc tout aussi intense, ce qui provoque
une forte répulsion.
Et c’est pour ça qu’un aimant tout simple
est suffisant
pour obtenir un phénomène de lévitation.
C’est comme si un supraconducteur avait
le pouvoir de se transformer exactement en
l’aimant opposé de celui qu’on lui présente.
On dit parfois que les supraconducteurs sont
super-diamagnétiques.
Mais à nouveau pourquoi ce serait le cas?
Quel rapport avec le fait de conduire le
courant sans résistance?
Dans la théorie de London dont
j’ai déjà parlé,
il existe une deuxième équation
qui permet d’expliquer ce lien.
Cette deuxième équation de London a
pour conséquence
un phénomène que l’on appelle parfois
l’expulsion du champ magnétique.
Si vous plongez un supraconducteur
dans un champ magnétique,
l’intensité du champ va décroître
très rapidement
au fur et à mesure que l’on s’enfonce
sous la surface du matériau.
En pratique le champ ne pourra exister
que dans une faible épaisseur,
et sera nul partout ailleurs.
Et cette propriété d’expulsion du champ,
c’est vraiment du super-diamagnétisme.
On applique un certain champ B,
et pour l’expulser,
donc faire en sorte que le champ total à
l’intérieur soit nul,
le matériau doit réagir en produisant
en son sein un champ exactement opposé, -B,
et la somme est donc 0.
Expulser le champ, et être super
diamagnétique,
avoir une susceptibilité de -1, c’est la
même chose.
Et avec un super diamagnétique, c’est facile
de faire de la lévitation avec un aimant.
Essayons de comprendre pourquoi
un supraconducteur réagit comme cela,
pourquoi serait-il super-diamagnétique?
Ce qu’il faut se dire déjà, c’est
qu’être diamagnétique,
c’est un peu le comportement normal
pour un matériau.
Je rentre pas dans les détails, mais
quand un champ magnétique provoque
le déplacement de charges électriques
comme les électrons dans un matériau,
cela se fait d’une façon qui vient
en général s’opposer au champ de départ.
Donc c’est assez naturel que la plupart
des matériaux
aient une susceptibilité légèrement négative.
Avoir une susceptibilité positive, être
attiré par les aimants,
comme pour le fer et le nickel,
c’est plutôt l’exception.
Maintenant pourquoi un supraconducteur serait
super-diamagnétique,
avec une susceptibilité négative,
mais très grande.
Eh bien une façon partielle de le comprendre,
c’est de se dire que le fait que le courant
y circule parfaitement
facilite l’établissement de petites boucles
de courants
qui vont s’opposer au champ magnétique
externe.
Cet argument n’explique pas complètement
l’effet Meissner,
mais ça montre qu’être, un conducteur parfait,
ça aide pour être super-diamagnétique,
et donc produire cet effet de lévitation.
En réalité, pour vraiment expliquer
l’effet Meissner,
il faut aller au-delà de l’idée
d’être un conducteur parfait.
L’effet Meissner, c’est un truc en plus.
Pour le comprendre, il faut tenir compte
du fait
que la supraconductivité est
un effet quantique.
En-dessous de la température critique, les
électrons subissent une transition
et se comportent en quelque sorte
d’une façon collective,
et c’est ce phénomène qui va induire
cet effet d’expulsion du champ magnétique.
Malgré tout il faut noter qu’à ce jour,
bien que tous les supraconducteurs connus
semblent manifester l’effet Meissner,
il n’existe pas de théorie
de la supraconductivité
qui permette d’expliquer tous les phénomènes,
en particulier
pour les supraconducteurs ayant
les températures critiques les plus élevées.
Mais ça, je vous en parlera
une prochaine fois.
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo!
Si vous avez tenu jusque là, n’hésitez pas
à vous abonner, si ça n’est pas déjà le cas.
Pour plus de détails, rendez-vous
sur le billet de blog,
le lien est en description.
Mettez la cloche et tout.
Partagez la vidéo pour m’aider
à faire connaitre la chaîne.
Et on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo,
à bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -